dans le nord de la france à quelques
kilomètres de lille roubaix
la mairie a décidé de lancer une
initiative innovante l'opération zéro
déchet donc voilà avant c'étaient tous
des paquets eaux usées pas attention
maintenant la pause et des boîtes
elle aussi est en mode zéro déchet elle
a délaissé les grandes surfaces avec
elle je redécouvre un lieu que j'avais
un peu déserté le marché nous réorienter
notre façon de consommer non seulement
ça retire les emballages mais en plus ça
remet en évidence ce dont on a besoin au
quotidien ou en vérité pourvu quoi
apprendre puis transmettre à travers
toute la ville le plus largement
possible
je pense qu'il doit y aurait crise de
conscience maintenant dans notre société
ça c'est sûr
de tension grâce au zéro déchet parce
qu'avant je ne vais quand même pas posé
la question aux déchets citoyens c'est
sur public sénat